こんにちははじめ社長ですおそらくこの客パーセントはこの家にネズミがいます下に
編集ビアがあるんですけども研修ベアで僕ひとりでずっとボーッとしてたらもの高い
なる棚の下の部分からたまに
っぽい音と事をちょっと撮って聞こえるんですよはいねずみもうねずみ確定ですまず
やってくれず深くて園には念を入れてひょっとしたらすごい巨大なネズミかもしれない
して小さいね
済みかもしれないどんなネズミにも対応できるように今日は超巨大なネズミ捕りを
仕掛けたいと思いますこちらろー企画
ネズミ捕り練り慶祝イージー bm あればでネズミを使われたやつなんですけども編
が2にょーん引き寄せます独占あるフェルは一切不使用
すごいぞこれはもうくっついては撮れませんからねそれで今日
とアポ20枚入ってるんですけどもネズミてる40万積んでして挙動いいかも
しれないけどたぶんねあのー取った巨大なんですよ多分巨大なんで今回は九大ねでね
捕獲大作戦ということでネズミ捕りをちょっと集中的にでかいでかい遺産の音釣りを
使える場所を作ってちょっと巨大出るできるのは待って金型脅迫しようと思いますの
どんなサイズのネズミ来るかわかんないんですけどもおそらくは小巨大サイズのネズミ
が出てくるんじゃないでしょ
いざ使う前行為
ここ周辺を狙って使われてると思いますよデイリするのは喧嘩んだから食べ
達としたら玄関法力グッズ日とかのいる月だから多摩エルダー多分玄関付近だと思い
ます z していきましょう
[音楽]
愛銃外で喧嘩を生産できました
これでダメネズミが外が帰ってきたときでもう of 頭に入って動けなくなってる
はずですではネズミをくるのを待ちましょう
そのネズミ捕りが効果あるかどうかって話でしょ
眺めちゃっちい来て空からなさそうな気がするんですよ
やってこれだけで云々にネズミが変わるらすぃですよ
本当かな
ファンランややばいやばいやばいやばいまたまたまたで前じゃないでは入ってますが
待って待って待って待ってはいただきたいん
納豆勝っていけばいいは取れない取れないと言うんだよ
ん
[音楽]
落ちない落ちラフエブリィ
伝え終わったなんてなってよは患者が医者ん
[音楽]
ぴょんぴょんぴょん
ちょち2+6 e 7
グラフィ nebel
re あっちょ
goo トゥディ
[音楽]
voodoo
person 音だった
すげー桜めぐり蔵王音ズレが使ったがやられた
終わらせんところですいやーはそして姉4分 at ペンどこ
俺
ああ
[音楽]
me
car
uh